Ladies, so today
I have a fun video idea.
I'm gonna share with you guys some tips and tricks
to feel more feminine and girly in the gym
and to appear that way.
And I understand that this is
something that a lot of girls want to feel,
and I totally get it.
So I hope these tips and tricks help you guys.
And I'm going to be sharing a little bit of
outfit inspiration in this video as well.
So let's get started.
So this was a really requested video I got
when I did a poll on Instagram
asking you guys what videos you wanted to see.
And feel free to comment here
under the comment section
what kind of videos you wanna see from me as well,
because I'm curious what you guys wanna see more of.
And, um. Anyways,
so let's get started on this video.
So the first thing you wanna remember
when it comes to dressing feminine in the gym is
do not let the way you look interfere with your workout
or getting yourself into the gym.
Because the most important thing is that you are
getting into the gym,
you are working on yourself.
You are, um, maybe strength training or cardio
or whatever you're doing,
you are bettering yourself and your health.
That is your priority.
Not looking super cute,
but there are a couple things you can do to make
yourself feel more confident when getting into the gym.
And I feel like this is a good time to make this video
because it's the beginning of January.
I think it's like
January 8th or something. So, yeah.
Tip number one is comfort and quality.
You wanna find workout clothes
that make you feel comfortable.
The fabric, the fit,
and that will make you feel the most confident.
So I understand that
some people don't like certain fabrics.
Some people like a really compressioned pair of pants.
Some people like something a little bit more relaxed.
Some people want to wear sweatpants,
some people want to wear leggings.
Find what makes you feel the most comfortable
and definitely stick with that style.
Personally, I have one pair of sweatpants,
and I try not to wear that
unless I'm doing something really dirty,
and I try to avoid that,
even at the gym.
But it's okay to wear sweatpants,
because I totally understand
the modesty behind wearing sweatpants.
But I wear leggings,
and that's just what I do.
And do what makes you feel comfortable.
And there is a way you can wear leggings
and be more modest in the gym,
and I'm gonna show you guys how you can do that.
So let's talk about quality.
I do think quality is important,
especially when it comes to working out.
The worst thing
that could possibly happen is if you're working out
and you feel like your pants are see through
or something's not holding up right.
You want to make sure
The quality of your clothes is good.
So I do recommend
splurging a little bit on workout clothes.
And when it comes to splurging on anything,
I highly recommend splurging on pants.
You can't go wrong with a good pair of pants.
I think you can actually
get cheaper tops
and that can totally work.
But when it comes to pants,
you really wanna make sure
that they are gonna hold up for your workout
and do what you need them to do.
This part is not budget friendly,
but I do really like Lululemon leggings.
I think that they hold up really well
and they do what they're supposed to do.
And the feeling of them,
the quality,
I think it's really great
and I would much rather have a nice pair of pants
than a nice top.
And you don't have to ever worry about pants being
see through with Lululemon.
At least I've never had that issue.
So I do recommend them.
And I will say this,
I have accumulated quite a few Lululemon clothes
because when I was in my bodybuilding phase,
having really nice workout clothes
was a really big priority of mine.
So I do highly recommend them.
But you don't need that many.
You can have two pair of pants and a couple tops
and just wash it more frequently.
The most important thing is that you are
getting in the gym.
So now let's talk about colors.
Colors I think
are so Important
because what you wear
and the color of it,
I think, can really help
when it comes to working out
and getting ready for the gym
and feeling cute.
So me personally,
I love bright colors,
and this is a pair of Lululemon pants.
These are just,
like, watercolor
floral pants.
They're, like,
my favorite pair,
and I don't know,
I feel more confident.
I feel really happy when I wear bright colors.
But my younger sister really likes dark colors,
so she has a lot of navy, blues,
dark purples,
blacks in her workout collection,
because that's what she feels most confident in.
So pick colors that make you feel confident
and make you feel happy.
So say I were to have these two pants,
the way I would style it is
I would get a gray
or a black top,
and then I would have a white top,
and then I have two pair of pants
and three tops,
and I could cycle them off,
and that way
I could still get to the gym
and still have cute workout clothes
and have good
quality workout clothes,
but I wouldn't have to worry about having
but so many.
And then over time,
you can add a little bit to your collection.
So now let's talk about styling a little bit.
So when it comes to the gym,
I'm really simple with my styling,
but you can add a little details
to make yourself feel a little more
Girly. So for me,
I love little scrunchies in my hair,
and I have quite a few colors,
and I just enjoy
kind of matching it to my top
or my pants
or something like that.
And that's what makes me feel, like,
cute. And I'm.
I'm really happy scrunchies made a comeback, because,
I don't know,
they're adorable.
But you could also put a little ribbon in your hair,
and it's a cute
little detail
that hopefully
keeps your hair pulled back.
But again, you want it to function properly
for your whole workout.
The last thing you wanna worry about is
your hair ribbon falling out
while you're running on the treadmill, right?
So that's not a priority,
but it can be a cute
little detail
if it works.
And now I wanna show you guys
how you can take a basic shirt
and a pair of leggings
and make it more modest,
especially if you're doing leg day
and you're in a co ed gym
and you just wanna cover up
when you're doing certain workouts
like squats or
Romanian deadlifts.
So what I always do is
I take a jacket with me to the gym,
and I tie it around my waist
like this, and it.
It's. It works great.
I can do my workouts,
and I don't have to worry about, um,
my behind sticking out and drawn all that attention.
So I always bring a jacket with me to the gym,
and I also Wear this when I'm doing cardio
or something like that.
But if you have longer shirts,
that works too.
And that is my other option
is I always bring an oversized shirt to the gym.
This is just my husband's shirt,
and I always bring this as well.
So it's either the jacket around the waist
or an oversized shirt
when I want to conceal more of my behind.
That's a little tip.
So when it comes to makeup or no makeup,
I think you should think about the rest of your day
after you workout and before you workout,
because I think it's just a personal preference.
I wear makeup to the gym.
I always have. I really.
I don't care to take off my makeup
just to go to the gym.
And it's never affected me to wear makeup.
But for some women,
they break out really bad
if they wear makeup to the gym.
So just figure out what works best for you.
But I don't think there's any shame
in wearing little makeup to the gym.
So another little tip I have
is wearing a little bit of a light,
light perfume.
This is just a peppermint perfume,
so it's very light
and it's very refreshing,
and it makes me feel a little bit more put together
when going to the gym,
and I smell more clean and stuff like that.
I wouldn't wear something super sweet to the gym.
I just wanna wear something light.
And refreshing.
So I think I found this one at a gas station.
I don't know.
Gym accessories.
Okay, this is really fun because
I kinda needed this stuff to go to the gym anyways
because this warms up my legs
and I can also use this for different workouts.
These are resistance bands,
and since I needed them anyways,
I invested in shades of pink
so there's medium
light and strong resistance.
So these are just like
one of those little cute things that make me feel
better when I do my workouts.
And they're a little bit more girly
and a little bit more feminine.
And I have my clips.
These are all from Amazon,
both the clips and the resistance bands.
And again, just a fun accessory.
I have pink ankle straps.
Again, these are on Amazon.
A pink gym bag.
This is Nike.
I've had this for like
seven years
and it holds up really great.
And a pink water bottle.
No, this is not a Stanley.
This is not a Hydro Flask.
This is some knock off one I found at TJ Maxx.
And I don't know,
it's like my comfort water bottle.
And one more tip I want to add
is invest in good quality sports bras
that hold yourself together
and make you feel more comfortable
when you're doing these different workouts in the gym.
That's really gonna be a lifesaver,
especially if you're running,
jumping, or doing anything like that.
So now I'm gonna show you guys a couple outfit ideas,
and these are all Lululemon.
I'm sorry these are not budget friendly.
I haven't shopped at Lululemon in 3 years,
so I don't know if this stuff's available,
but I'm gonna show you anyways.
So those are some tips
for dressing and feeling more feminine in the gym.
And if I can think of any more tips,
I will make a part 2.
But anyways,
thanks for watching. Bye!